uh
because what i read about him you know
and
and study about him over the years
because you want to know what the family
was like
they say based on what you read about he
was
more psychopath he was a psycho he was
meaner he was more vicious than his
father ever was
he took the level of viciousness to new
heights is that a pretty true statement
or
was his father more vicious than he was
no he is he passed his father
he passed a lot at least his father when
he was doing
all this stuff he have strategy
in his life he was doing that
for a politic issue for
something he want to get an error
but today he was doing it for
many acting is nothing is benefit of him
uh you don't know what he wants
sometimes you see him really laugh with
a big mouth
and half an hour later sitting in a
corner
crying like a baby that's kind of a
personality you don't know what he wants
you don't know why he's doing that
uh
when he drunk uh twice i heard from him
he said to me my dad don't like me he
like kosai more on me
this is why he don't want to give me a
power this is why he because i
as ahead of his security he didn't put
me
i want to answer him but i i know my
neck would
be bye bye now kosai was a little bit
more reserved to himself he was a
little shy little quiet but he was
calculating he had his dad's
calculating side based on what i read
about him uh
uh but he wasn't that uh well public
about it
and i know i know there was one time
where he became the leader of secret
service and his dad i think in 1984
made the uday the chairman of the iraqi
olympic uh
committee yeah and he wanted to service
yeah
jose the second son he's more close to
his dad this is why his dad
trusts him more one he's not like oh
they
he married even he's the youngest one
he's very very clever for me personally
i like him
uh very very intelligent
he treats his people with him as a
friend
and a brother he don't hurt him like are
they what he do
if he don't like you even your clothes
and my group
are so fun they say okay take him
shave his head shave his eyebrows uh
sent him to this place where he tortured
okay just for fun for 10 days
enough he's joking and this is what he
do but
jose no no he give a chance second
he sit with you talk in a human way
uh sometimes he said you don't look at
me saddam er
son look at me also brother to your
friend
why you behave like that but
saddam and kosai there was very
hard and strong with their family
and they tried for example if any iraqi
do something wrong i give an example
maybe get forgiveness and a lot of
forgiveness happened at the time
but anybody belong to saddam family
cousin or cousin of cuisine or common
from tikrit
he been 10 times punished more on normal
person
because saddam and kosair was telling
them
when you behave like that you hated my
name
and saddam to be very honest with you he
was caring about his name so much
i saw one of his
he was captain yeah he was captain
one of the times they sent me for
torture
and while saddam closes sick
you know security with him and from
tikrit
because he did something unusual in the
street
you know he he hit the traffic light or
something was red and but
he sent him where i was being tortured
for a month
and he's a captain and he's a dumb
family
because he hit a red light yeah
he said because you behave you are
belong to saddam name when people
know you are my bodyguard and behave
like that how the normal people go to
respect the law the
the the the fi it seemed like the father
and the son were always uh
at war like uh saddam and uday i
remember one time i think they did uh
did they one time accidentally shoot off
his uh
uncle saddam's uh uh brother brother
to that story uh this is after i left
oh that's after you right here yeah
after i left i heard
from one of these guys was with him
but i tell you about tamil hannah
was saddam food tester and
his sadami was calling me calling him
son you know more very close to him he's
a christian person
but he and his family work all for
saddam since
he was kid and
i remember was a party
and mubarak
of egypt ex uh president
visit iraq and
carmel hannah did a party for them you
know as a welcome into the country
i think by order of saddam to do welcome
and party for them
we was uh
like a few buildings and i'll have
vanilla and
we're coming from habanero to this place
where it's called
probably palace
space or something like that as i can't
translate it exactly in english
i was sitting and all day he was going
around
camel hannah invited every single one
except all day and
at the time was a few months
or less a year for them married secretly
and this is what i break the news when i
come
out another woman
her name is amira and
[Music]
was through canal hannah and today he
hated
camel hannah because of that how you get
a woman
and is that of my mother and here
was a war between them but he can't
touch him because
he know how valuable camel hanna to
saddam and very close to him
he can't touch him anyway
he started drinking he can hear the
music and the singer from the other side
how did he say to one of
these guys around him go tell him
because camel hannah
i think he become a little bit drunk he
took his machine gun a celebration you
know middle east
as a welcome
he told him go tell this idiot just stop
shooting
he went and he saw carmel and he was
shooting
and tamil hannah told him tell all day
i'm not taking over of him
the only person i took order from saddam
hussein
and like i was sitting in the couch and
my leg is up
and another guy was having fun drink
oh they he have like a
sticker but very long with a hard head
and you can't take take it up
as a sword when you pull it up with the
sword inside
he went and we go after him where are
you going
nobody talk to me nobody pushing here
i'm pushing here we want around
you want to come with hannah
with this heavy stick straight away to
his head
few times you can see the blue just keep
going keep going
take the knife straight away cut his
neck
take the gun start shooting here and
there
everyone terrified they took mubarak
wife in a different car
and straight away
the palace informed tamil hannah have
been shot and winded
on that i remember the president coming
into the garden with the cars
a day he run to where we was
he went to the bathroom and closed the
door shut it down completely
screaming in the bathroom
we try to open the door asking him to
open the door
nothing he keeps screaming screaming
till completely the voice is gone
and no more he can't i can't hear we
call him
we call him no answer we break the door
he was on the floor he took a lot of
tablets was
i don't know what they are a lot he took
it a lot he want
to kill himself
put them in the car to the hospital was
hospital belong to the palace called
avensina and
this hospital they did what they did
with him
uh we was around him president come on
uh but he looked at everyone as a
piece of dirt uh
why he didn't stop him on this he took a
date
he wasn't lying in the bed and took him
like that
start slapping him you must be dead
you must be this is your shame in me
shaming the family
and anyway i will put you in the jail
for all your life and if i can
hang you but i leave this to the justice
visa
and he put saddam order
he put the
george is the
one of the most powerful person in iraq
and he say don't look at him as my son
judge him
as a murderer for any person
and believe it or not okay we say what
they say is a dumb dictator
and like that but the george
he sent all day to that penalty